I'm, like,
stoked right now.
I bet you are.
I know you.
Clancy! Welcome back!
How was your vacation?
Oh, it was amazing. Thank you
guys so much for the itinerary.
Now, tell me you went
to that café.
Oh, best biscotti
I've ever had.
That biscotti ruined me
for American biscotti.
Did you go
on the hike?
Yes!
Oh, the vista!
All the vistas in America
are trash.
Did you --
Yes. Amazing.
What is this place?
[ Gasps ]
Oh, Kate.
The beauty
is indescribable,
but here's
what it looked like.
It's God's country.
I'm gonna have an eighth
of my ashes scattered there.
[ Whispering ]
You've seen trees before,
but when you go there,
you'll realize
you had no fucking clue
what trees were.
[ Normal voice ]
They call it Trivallo.
Trivallo?
Unh-unh.
Together: Tri-vaaaaaah-o.
It's economically
decimated.
But culturally,
it's bursting with riches.
I bought a magnet
with my name on it.
There's this restaurant.
It's in the ocean.
You have to try it.
Now, you're gonna get wet,
but that's part of it.
[ Whispering ] You must try
the Eucharist at the cathedral.
It ruined me
for American Eucharist.
[ Normal voice ]
Best ruins I've ever seen.
Ruined me
for American ruins.
Now, I don't
wanna oversell it,
but let's just say
you are finally gonna understand
why I started spelling "color"
with a "U."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Goodbye, everyone!
I'm off to Trivallo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Birds chirping ]
[ Biscotti crunches ]
[ Coughing ]
So...
how was it?
It was...
♪♪
...amazing!
[ All sigh ]
You two
have to go.
-Nah.
-Okay.